[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
hey i saw you on the twitter thank you
all right thank you very much
good all right how you guys doing
geez uh this is as you probably know
this is not the show we expect
is that a dog i thought i was gonna be
the biggest violation of code tonight
guys brought a yorkie okay so listen
this obviously that light went out there
uh naked jared just so hey knocking
jared everybody he's here
so hold on a second before i move on oh
damn it some of you have seen my binder
but don't ruin it for the people behind
you
this is our first time doing a change my
mind live broadcast
anyone know the topic of tonight it's a
new topic we've never done this before
can we unravel this and show it to the
crowd before we get on the table
all right let's get out and show it to
the crowd of course anyone is welcome it
is
[Applause]
cheers people socialism is evil
what do you have to say about you guys
thank you so much
this is not the show we planned on doing
we anyone here see the smu show last
week
how ridiculous was anyone want a show
like that yeah
well we couldn't because your uh your
campus officers
actually wouldn't show up so hold on a
second there's one who did show up today
there's one who showed up let's give it
up for officers still uh sillerson
one who showed up and uh there are some
private security details out here who
are off-duty officers and just so you
know the same lieutenant who told them
that noah would show up because there
was no credible threat told these
off-duty officers you can't carry on
campus
well he called someone above the
lieutenant's head and he said what that
guy what's he do
you carry and i quote you carry your
[ __ ] gun
[Applause]
and a lot of them are amongst you who
you do not know um
so thank you so much there was a mix-up
obviously we couldn't get out here and
do the show that we want to do it's
going to be kick-ass we wanted to do
this whole like smu
but instead we loaded all of our misfits
into a bus
and shipped them across country against
their will gross violation of labor laws
we said we can't do the big comedy show
we'll come back and do it but we can do
one hell of a change my mind cause all
we need is a table some coffee and some
good conversation are we right
right huh
thank you guys and one guy just yelled
and weed what was that and a pin
all right first off i can't see while
i'm in here is there anyone out there
who disagrees and would like to change
my mind on the idea that's the premise
that socialism is evil
okay now by the way okay we see one
person all right let's uh let's bring
one person in to start
hold on one second hold on no no no hold
on hold on hold on
we got to pick one person there's two
hands going up are you an actual
are you okay one second here one second
one second all right and this is why
this is why we had to downscale this but
by the way i appreciate
we actually have the ability to see any
leftist organization in the country
and how many people show up and just so
you know every time there's an antifa
protest
unless they're stabbing ben shapiro with
an axe pick uh every time there's an
antifa protest or occupy and they post
something
we can actually say that on average
about eight percent of people who claim
they'll be attending attend
whereas here this is the last minute
there was a cancellation we said hey
guys we're gonna be in the quad
and i think it's actually two to three
times the number of people who said they
were coming so you guys actually show up
and i know that's hard because many of
you have jobs so um
so that's we're gonna be talking about
tonight for those who don't know this
isn't a comedy show
i know some people were saying well why
don't you come here and do a lecture be
like having alice cooper play
jazz piano at carnegie hall i don't do
lectures it's not fun
but with this the goal here is not to by
the way just to argue it's not ad
hominem it's the opposite of cable news
if someone disagrees with me i want to
sit down and we use a credit method to
rationalize their position now i know a
lot of you won't be able to see me or
hear me so i wouldn't blame you if you
walk out like i said this was last
minute planned we appreciate every one
of you who is here
but i would love to sit down with
someone who disagrees with me and
everyone here by the way i know how high
energy you are
but make sure you give respect to anyone
who sits down and disagrees and give
them the chance to make their argument
so hopefully we can be productive not
get jared uh who do we want who do we
want to grab who's grabbing who
people keep saying messenger bag so mr
messenger bag hold on one second come on
out one second come here come toward me
we're gonna have someone pat you down
real quick
got one person who can pat him down not
gay jared there you go
i fulfilled my legal obligations
all right listen what's your name sarah
ian ian in brass balls come sit down
appreciate it give me your out of the
hand
[Music]
a round of a hand i don't even know what
that means all right
what was that actually by the way
by the way because i know many of you
here are still reeling from your
rejections from northwestern
um oh
don't insult or ban up come on that's
asking a sparrow not to sing
urbana champagne as we call it the gates
of hell
you're like detroit without the balls to
follow through all right
we're kidding but depaul actually has
rescinded their decision and we will be
going to depaul
sometime next semester and i'm kidding
urbana's the best city in america all
right
so i believe hopefully people can hear
me we're just going to sit down and and
go through this
point by point to see where we find
common ground uh it's the first time
we've ever broadcast it live a lot of
people say well we think maybe you edit
it
or hand pick opponents hey can not can
someone actually grab some water here
and give him a closed bottle so that you
know he doesn't uh
accuse us of opponents it is a really
nice moment they ordered mine like
four weeks wait you ordered one yeah
what that means you're a fan you can't
come up here no
no no i still have thoughts no you still
have thoughts no get out of here we have
to have someone else who disagrees
you can't be a fan who here actually
disagrees with me i appreciate it i
appreciate it brother
afterwards not evil though it's not it
is evil you this guy seems to be really
eager or this guy in the orange
all right
okay well let's bring up the guy in the
orange sorry
i know i know but listen we didn't plan
on this we have no idea we usually just
show up and do it and people want us
to get out what's your name sir alex
alex are you holding up did you go here
uh no i go to urbana high school oh alex
we got we can't do
hold on a second hold on a second if i
if i do this with a high school student
next thing that's going to happen is
they're going to laura ingram me and say
that i mocked someone who's not of age
are you 18 your parents have to give you
permission i can't i can't actually film
you i appreciate it alex i'm sorry
this guy come on let's bring this guy up
here i'm so sorry this is the process
we don't want to break the law
because we only have one officer who
showed up because that's all you need
for a crowd like this
all right what is your name sir yousef
yousef nice to meet you steven
so i believe let me explain my position
i believe that socialism
is fundamentally uh evil and i have this
here we usually don't reference this but
it's sources in case someone wants to
look at them afterward but
i don't think i won't use it it's not
fair for me to use them so i believe
socialism
is evil you disagree i would love to
hear you change my mind okay well what's
your position on the minimum wage
hold on a second uh is this your this is
you're changing my mind i want to make
sure yes i want to get started okay my
position the minimum wage yeah
uh you know what uh i'm not a fan so you
think there shouldn't be any minimum
wage at all
not a fan okay are you against illegal
immigration and legal immigration from
poor third world countries
at the scale that we've been having it
so far oh yeah
am i against illegal immigration the
answer what was that
but we're gonna do everything we can
like we said this is last minute because
uh
we're not necessarily friendly here uh
i'm again no i mean
they don't consider us friendly so like
i said we appreciate you supporting us
of course i'm against illegal
immigration but
again socialism i believe the idea of
socialism let's do this before we go on
okay
cause this is something and that's i
think this is important this is
something we often see from both the
right and the left
see we started with the premise where i
made a statement socialism is evil
right and you've moved on to different
questions different topics so i'd like
to first before we move on if you
if if it's okay let's define socialism
okay
how do you define socialism so i know
that we're agreeing on
on that premise socialism is a system in
which the state
redistributes wealth uh from what it
would be under a pure capitalist system
okay i think we agree on that okay and
then i think it's important
but don't give up this is just an actual
discussion i might be wrong here
um and what it what do you think i mean
by evil or what would we both agree
the definition of evil is harmful to
society
not necessarily to society i believe
morally reprehensible it's immoral okay
so so as we both agreed socialism is
basically a collective a governmental
control
of the distribution or product means of
distribution or production
and when i say evil i mean i believe
that that is immoral
so can we both agree with that i don't
agree that it's evil no no but we agree
you agree that's what i'm saying that's
my position yes okay so what part of my
position
do you disagree with again the goal here
is to change my mind not score points
well i'm trying to convince you that
your own objectives if you're a
conservative
cannot be achieved under capitalism okay
and so i'll give you an example of that
yeah um you have a lot of republicans
like paul ryan who are obstructing
donald trump
well hold on hold on
you cannot deny that he is a big
capitalist and he has lots of capitalist
donors that would like nothing more than
to increase their profits i think you
can agree with that
and people like that have been opposing
immigration reform for decades
because they believe that mass
immigration will lower the wages of the
working class
and increase their profits now i would
say a lot of what you just said is
correct
okay and that many uh conservatives
republicans believe
that mass immigration from countries
like say mexico
from quote-unquote third world countries
could lower the wages yeah i do believe
that a lot of republicans believe that
okay so i would agree with you on that
so if you impose a minimum wage you're
not going to have this mass immigration
coming in because the companies that are
taking these illegal immigrants and
taking these low-wage immigrants if they
had to pay them 15
an hour we wouldn't have mass
immigration like we're having right now
yeah i don't necessarily know that i
agree with that premise so let me kind
of go um
because first off before i would like to
take that hold it
what example we point to before we go on
because i know a lot of times i disagree
of a successful socialist country
well there are different kinds of
socialism i think you're thinking of the
soviet union in venezuela when you say
these are unsuccessful countries
but you also have sweden you have norway
you have finland you have denmark of
germany
these are countries that have robust
economies and high levels of
socialization
right uh what's their minimum wage
i don't have the numbers off the top of
my head what if i told you that they
have no minimum wage
there are plenty of countries at a high
minimum wage australia has a high
minimum wage i know but we didn't talk
about them we talked about
successful socialist economies now first
off i think it's interesting
this is important because we need to
find the premise first off we're away
from the premise which is the moral
argument
i believe socialism is immoral the
redistribution of something that you
have not earned
i believe is fundamentally immoral i
believe that's theft are you an anarchy
hold on a second hold on a second
then we'll go in so now we moved on from
that to the pragmatic and no i'm not an
anarchist
um and then you brought up some
successful examples in denmark norway
sweden i believe first off these aren't
socialist countries now the reason we
would point to countries like say
venezuela or cuba
for the same reason bernie sanders did
for decades is because they're true
examples of socialism
uh the danish prime minister said bernie
stop referring to us as a socialist
economy we're a free market economy
they don't have a minimum wage as we
know it they only allow collective
bargaining between unions
higher skilled unions and those who
their employers
so these are countries by the way if you
want to get into their immigration laws
the only way to make it work if you
refer to those countries i mean i guess
i would have to ask it sounds almost as
though you're making an argument are you
uh
are you a nationalist i would say i'm an
economic nationalist
you are an economic nationalist okay so
there goes you part ways with a lot of
probably your your more left-leaning
brethren
i never said i was a liberal okay so
you're a conservative socialist
they're they're hard to come back
so no minimum wage there but again this
doesn't change the idea let's get to the
fundamental premise yeah before we move
on to the pragmatic and i'd be happy to
but i believe that socialism the ism
that we both agreed upon
the collective means seizing of
distribution production
um is immoral well i mean the argument
is absurd because if you say that it's
immoral then you also have to say that
government funding of police is a moral
government funding of the military is
immoral anything the government does is
immoral and that's ridiculous because
you have to have some state that's going
to
socialize certain things and so the
question is not do we have socialization
it's how much
sure um i would disagree with that now
would you would you know where i
disagree with that
guess what i'm going to say i assume
you're going to try to argue that
government funding of the military and
police is not socialism
why would i say that uh well because if
you don't argue that then you're going
to have to give some ground
on socialism no absolutely i think
you're right if i if i have to concede
that
police force as he's saying police force
military
roads is socialism the same as health
care
education and i'm assuming that's why
you're referring to denmark and sweden
they're not socialist economies but they
have more of a social safety net
that's kind of what you're talking about
right yeah they're social democracies
they're well they're they're market
economies with
higher emphasis on a social safety net
that's how they describe that's what a
social democracy is
so so okay we agree on the term let's go
with social democracy i just want to
make sure we don't get confused like
democratic socialism so that changes
anything
but um we just talked about this uh
conceding that ground i don't believe
that the military
and the police force would be the same
as
socialized healthcare school why not
sorry because we only have one
microphone we had to do a late set up i
appreciate you working with me
well i mean why not why not was your
question our definition was so why not
yeah
okay so make sure you don't um why not
because there's a difference between a
public good
and a commodity can you explain to me
the difference between public goods and
a commodity
well in economics a public good is uh a
good that is i believe non-excludable
and non-rivalrous
so exactly so that would include things
like
the police the military you'd be
hard-pressed to even find hardcore
libertarians to say that we don't need
those
so there's a big difference there's a
fundamental difference between that
and something like healthcare or school
it's still or it goes to
free internet as you know sven computer
talked about in germany you know high
speed internet is a right the second you
declare any commodity to be a right
or to be a fundamental role of
government that means the government can
now remove that right depending on who's
in power and that's the problem that's
why i think it's fundamentally immoral
for someone to take something they
haven't earned regardless of who's in
power i think it's immoral for donald
trump's administration to take it from
you
just as you probably think it's immoral
for barack obama's administration to
take it from me
um so the difference there would be
first public goods versus commodity
i think it's an important distinction
for everyone here to make because it's a
common argument we hear from the left if
you support any role of government at
all
that means that this is socialism but
it's not according to the definition
that we agreed upon
something else i think it also matters
the constitutional parameters of
government
right what the constitution defines what
our government is and what fundamental
human rights
are well i want to get back to your
earlier point where you said that
because
uh the military is a public good that
that therefore it's not socialism um in
your definition you never made any
distinction between different types of
goods you just said a socialist economy
is one that
takes wealth from some people and gives
it to others and that's what financing a
public good is
what no no it's not you talked about
redistributing the redistribution
the common means of production or
distribution
so if we want to frame that in i
certainly wouldn't say that that's the
police
oh someone's yelling hopefully we're
good uh so i would not agree with if the
military or police
would be socialist but um to move on
here again let's go to the
dane danes the danes
denmark norway sweden you pointed to
them as successful examples
of socialism because that would be
different from your definition of
socialism so now i've moved on from the
idea
that taking something you haven't earned
to give to someone else is morally
reprehensible regardless of the reason
because socialism can only be enacted to
the threat of violence
that's really what taxes are at the end
of the day we all agree on that
violence is part of life okay well i
don't believe there should be a part of
life for someone with guns to come in
if i don't pay for timmy's health care i
just disagree with that if you don't pay
taxes you're going to have
other forms of violence that arise
spontaneously this this sort of autistic
libertarian idea
of oh you can you can have a
non-aggression stop it stop it he's been
watching that damon videos
this idea of a non-aggression principle
is is just fantasy
okay you have to have described me you
just said autistic and this was very
civil until you brought that up
define autistic here well
it tends to be characterized by an over
an over emphasis on logic and philosophy
as opposed to reality
you know it's very easy to argue from
syllogisms and axioms and all that
so hold on a second i want to make sure
before you because now what you do is
you speak in these paragraphs we need to
determine what these definitions are i
think we both agree that's fair
fine okay so you just said that autism
if i'm not mistaken and i would love for
you to bring this up
is rooted more in philosophy and
theology than facts
then logically that sort of thing that's
what you believe is the definition of
autism
well because it leads you down these
intellectuals do you believe that's the
definition of autism no
i know you don't get an informal way
okay so you're using an insulting way
you could say that okay a little bit of
banter a little bit yeah well we don't
call that friendly banter generally we
call that being a dick
so i want to go back to hopefully
keeping it civil you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't call you [ __ ] you know i
wouldn't say that you had a fight with
the clippers and the clippers won i
wouldn't do this
let's keep this very civil so let's go
back to sweden denmark norway
as examples you pointed to them as
successful examples of socialism is
interesting to me that you said
i know you'd want to point to the ussr
or venezuela or these places but really
we should look to these scandinavian
countries
sure why because they provide a good
quality of life for their citizens you
don't have this gigantic gap between the
working class and the upper class
there is a commitment of the state to
the well-being of their citizens and i
think that's a wonderful thing
okay so first first off i i agree with
you
first off the overall well-being of
citizens is a tremendous thing i think
we would all want i think everyone here
wants a better society wants a better
america
i don't think that you want a worse
america i hope that you don't believe i
want to worse america despite the fact
that you
implied i might be autistic so maybe i
don't know what's best for america
you know autistic and such um keep your
hand speech off this campus
but your reason your reasoning there
and correct me if i'm wrong you said
there isn't the same kind of gap the
inequality gap that was your
i want to get because you speak in like
i said in longer paragraphs it seems the
fundamental premise there was denmark
norway sweden they're examples because
they're successful they have a higher
quality of living and the main purpose
you the main justification used was
there's less of an inequality
gap am i correct i don't want a
misrepresentation yes okay
so your problem is with inequality it's
one of several problems i think
another problem but that was your first
issue let's go point by point
okay inequality what's immoral about
inequality
because there's this idea that you're
going to have this society
and everybody has social obligations but
if you have a situation where people are
being crushed or where people's wages
are going down
you lose the social cohesiveness of that
society you lose the commitment that
everybody has to advance
because now you're getting into
potential results the hypothetical
almost autistic one could say but
i ask again what is immoral about
inequality what's immoral is that it
ruins the society that's what's immoral
about it
how does inequality ruin society because
it sounds it sounds to me if i'm not
mistaken what you just went down to
describe
was a problem with poverty yeah so your
problem is with poverty then
but but uh poverty is a consequence of
inequality that's not necessarily true
but and as a matter of fact i would
argue that there are two very different
things uh because i would say and i
think we probably have to agree that the
free enterprise
westernized capital system has pulled
more people up out of poverty than any
system in existence
and if you look at countries you said
don't point to countries like venezuela
or true socialist economies
uh there's tremendous equality but
everyone is equally poor
um so the problem you have is with
poverty it sounds like and i think we
both have a problem with that that we
want to solve
ways to eliminate as much poverty as
possible it's not just poverty
inequality matters too
because if you have inequality of wealth
you're going to have an upper class that
controls the political system
and secures its own interests instead of
the interests of the people so yes
inequality matters as well
okay so describe to me and then i'd like
to go back to
examples of this the upper ruling class
determining the political system
you want examples of that yeah i would
like some examples of that sure
because i believe so for example let's
say uh you know you mentioned that
inequality hurts people
i would argue no and i think that's
because again this is a more of a
leftist view i know you said you're not
really liberal but i can tell you by
your worldview on economics that you do
lean more left because you're seeing it
as a zero-sum game
wealthy people can't get wealthy off of
the backs of poor people if they make
them more poor
that's kind of if we're going to talk
about motives and attributing motives
that you've done a couple of times here
if i believe uh that if i want everyone
to be wealthy
i would necessarily if i need a system
of government that would require that
would want people to be wealthy would
require
people to be wealthy for someone who
would want to control a system of
government like in socialist economies
who would want to consistently talk or
gain the votes of the poor
they could only be elected if people are
poor bernie sanders is not going to be
elected by a rich country
we're not trying to make everybody rich
that's not possible we're trying to
create a fair distribution of wealth but
i want to get back to your earlier
question about how are the
wealthy controlling the political yeah
so let's an example of that i don't
believe that any quality necessarily
hurts them i don't believe it's a
zero-sum game
you know for example uh tim cook and i
don't like tim cook by the way
i know apple people android they're
gonna start yelling um
tim cook creating a better iphone even
though the iphone 10 kind of sucks
uh thank you that's where i get the
passion uh that doesn't hurt me him
making billions of dollars that doesn't
hurt me
poverty breadlines 160 for for a dozen
eggs
that hurts me i have a problem with
poverty i don't care if someone else has
more than me
so long as i have a system where i'm
able to do okay do you understand that
it's the upper class and the capitalists
that want mass immigration
and want illegal immigration because
it's in their economic self-interest if
you're a republican and you're with the
capitalists
you're going against your own interests
the capitalists are not conservative
they're not well honestly we're talking
about capitalist conservative republican
here
so you're saying that capitalism we're
talking about the ism now socialism
versus capitalism i don't care what paul
ryan does in his own
time i don't care what his front-page
newspress is doing p90x and what he
thinks about immigration i couldn't care
less
i don't believe in him i don't i don't
believe uh it seems that you would agree
in securing the borders
you would agree in stricter immigration
it would and it's not you're not going
to get it if you show for the
capitalists
well they're against you define shill
well if you're if you've got i know you
like to sound really intelligent
paragraphs one thing you've misused
words several times
and if someone were to call you on it
and be as rude as you are you might look
what you might refer to as stupid okay
so saying autistic or shill
define because it's a very specific
definition you came in and just said
shill
and i'm really quickly to given get
ready to give the microphone to someone
else if you don't stop doing this
because this isn't the goal of this
what's a shill
well i think you're getting upset
because you're losing a debate but
that's fair that's fair what's a shill
no no the person losing the debate is
the one who refers the other person is
autistic and a shill that's generally a
good sign
so what's a shill i don't have the exact
definition but essentially someone who's
uh
i guess uh pushing or advancing somebody
else's interest i suppose
for profit fair enough but a lot of
these conservatives who well you're not
talking to these conservatives you're
talking to me
this isn't this isn't a performance paul
here that's why we're doing this out
here this is a conversation you're
talking to me i just said that i'm
against
illegal immigration okay you can look
you're looking at i'm not mad at you i
just i just think it's rude
it's okay don't worry i mean it's okay
i'm used to people being rude to me i'm
sure you're probably aware this to one
degree or another
uh let's move back to again norway
sweden we didn't really kind of go to
that you've talked about them as
successful examples
now we refer and i would agree i would
agree that if we're going to
take a model and say they've created a
social safety net that functions
better than many other countries for
example socialized healthcare and
education
uh yeah what's wrong with that good well
like so you would support school
vouchers
i think you know in general vouchers i
think have a problem because they do
lead to the incentivization of private
schools but but anyway that the
government
that's i just said because that's what
sweden does yeah so you would support
more of a flat tax
and uh increasing taxes on the middle
class and the lower class i want a
progressive tax
okay well that's not what happens in
denmark they should change it
okay so we would want a lower corporate
tax rate
not necessarily okay so here's the one
thing we point to and then i appreciate
you taking what's your name again
yousef i appreciate you have taken the
time everyone give a hand to yousef
appreciate it very much we'll grab
someone else here thank you
this is always interesting to me because
we talk about this a lot and i know and
if we look here
uh just so i think we've talked about
this we're going to be actually selling
for like five or six bucks i'm not
looking for we're gonna be selling the
change my mind pamphlet so that you guys
can actually prepare some of these
arguments
uh right here on page three i actually
have if anyone here you know what look
kind of like a magician
oh you have a maga hat can you come here
really quickly
what did i what are the words written
down right there denmark
denmark sweden and norway
and norway so if you guys know where
people are going to try and direct the
conversation you don't get distracted by
words like you know autistic or shill
which is what they throw out you can be
prepared very often for for how people
disagree now here's the thing
to provide a brief education on denmark
sweden and norway i didn't think that
was going to go
anywhere super productive they made
their wealth long before
they became what you would call
socialist economies now by the way
they're not socialist economies the
danish prime minister when bernie
sanders was saying we should be like
denmark socialist he said shut up
he said he said we're a free market
economy and we place emphasis on social
safety nets which they are now scaling
back
here's what's so interesting there if
you look they have far lower corporate
tax rates
than the united states we have does
anyone know the corporate tax rate in
the united states
the marginal highest tax rate yes 35 but
now it's 27 with the taxes it would go
down to yes the marginal rate i believe
was up as high as 39 30.
39 i think 35 but the marginal highest
tax rate was 39 and in norway
denmark sweden i think the highest they
have is 25 some of them have it as low
as 22.
so a good 10 points lower so they have
corporate taxes low
i think if you're comparing to the
united states if you make 1.2 times the
average
income so the united states that would
be 50 000 if you make 60 000
you'd be paying 60 income tax so what
they do is they understand that they
can't stifle businesses
they have lower corporate tax rates and
the united states doesn't sound very
socialist
and they have increased taxes on the
middle and lower classes they pay more
tax everyone pays some
something by the way super well it's
changing but at one point super strict
immigration laws not everyone gets to
take part in the social safety net if
you haven't paid in
and again these are people who have the
population about the size of
ohio or michigan so to compare an
entirely homogenous population
uh to a country of 300 something million
people by the way i'm against illegal
immigration
but the big difference between us and
denmark and norway and sweden
is we're not a people we're a country of
ideals and if you're willing to come in
and make a go of it we're gonna provide
you with equal opportunity not ensure
equal outcome
that's the difference that requires a
racial national identity
and a constitutional republic
[Applause]
so ironically socialism almost
invariably tends to be racist
to a certain degree which is uh funny
when we say national socialism
democratic socialism
theft is theft if you're taking it if
it's ill-gotten gay and something you
haven't earned theft is theft
something else i also find very
interesting and i'll just talk about
this i just wanted to bring this up so
you could see that
these are things you can prepare for
these are very common arguments um
very interesting if we take that kind of
cultural social fabric of denmark norway
sweden
so take them they do have a higher
standard of living on average
than the average american but if you
take the danes
who are in america if you take swedish
americans if you take norwegian
americans
they actually have on average a 55
higher standard of living index
than the swedes in sweden so it's
because they've brought a culture with
them again if you look at the very
storied culture of hard work ethics
personal accountability of shame they do
better there and they do far
better in the united states than even in
their homeland so you get people have
that work ethic who have that kind of
cultural fabric who have that
history and you give them a free
enterprise system my god watch them
bloom but i appreciate
i forgot his name yusuf thank you very
much does anyone else want to disagree
yeah yusuf yes all right i see
balls of steel thank you and by the way
i do mean yusef does have balls of steel
to sit
down and do this i have tremendous
amount of respect for anyone who enters
the arena
um yeah i know i hear some people yell i
don't want to yell anyone down
like i said this is not this is not the
show that we wanted to do we'll bring
that back through
this is we've never done this usually
change my mind is sitting down with a
couple of people
not a few hundred people out there in a
quad with a don't tread on me flag
looks like the patriot he's going to be
hitting someone with a tomahawk
yes pink floyd shirt i guess you you
have your hand up now you're not a fan
correct
no no we can't do that we gotta have
people who disagree i appreciate it
yes i can't see could you pat him down
hold on let not get jared pat you down
mr illinois
it's okay
thank you i love you too like i said i'm
really i
thank you guys so much for hanging out
we appreciate it i know it's not what we
plan to do cheap pin
someone i don't know what this is but i
know someone's going to complain about
it so i'll have to look at it later
uh i can't wear a pin that i'm thinking
someone hands me a pin like where it's
like i can put it on and
anthrax i have no idea what's your name
sir i'm drew
drew nice to meet you drew appreciate it
uh so again like i said i believe that
that socialism
the ism socialism is fundamentally evil
immoral um and if you disagree with me
and you think you can change my mind i'm
i'm obviously elaborate just a little
bit on like
what evil like what you mean by evil i
mean immoral immoral okay um
well i actually i wrote a paper on this
um a couple years ago
and i mean i'm not an expert by any
means but
why would you bring up the paper what oh
okay all right all right i'm kind of i'm
kind of an expert
but i think that um based on like
research from like past
uh countries that capitalism is great
when a country is trying to get back on
its feet
um but i think once you kind of i don't
want to say peak as a country but
economically once you kind of reach that
stability and like you feel like your
economy is thriving i think then there
should be a shift towards socialism but
not
i don't think a full-blown like
socialism reform
socialist reform by any means but i
think like i would
so how would you define social women
because they wouldn't go full blown so i
want to make sure i
agree i mean it in the sense is a
redistribution of wealth but i
not to the extent of communism um okay
so here
well sorry my right your left here's
anarchy
here's communism here's free enterprise
here'd be socialism and he'd be kind of
the middle yeah okay
um i just want to make sure yeah okay
because like a utopian
capitalism capitalist economy is anarchy
okay
utopian socialism socialist country is
um communist um which so i'm not as far
as the communists although i think both
of us could probably i have no idea what
i know now they're teaching in school
anarcho-communism have you heard of this
it seems redundant doesn't it yeah i
know people told me i was the idiot
because i was like that doesn't make
sense
yeah that's totally stupid look we found
common ground yeah um
it's very rare nowadays yeah i did a
video there look common ground
and by the way you seem very friendly i
appreciate you being respectful um
so again it doesn't this is one thing
that i find pretty common with to change
my mind
um and i think this is important because
we have changed quite a few minds with
the segment
a lot of people come back and said hey
you know what i didn't think about this
before or i hadn't looked at it from
that angle before
um the premise in addressing the premise
is important if someone fundamentally
and that's why it's framed this way
believes that something
is evil or immoral yeah if if you don't
get them off of that
you have almost you know if i can't
convince the mother i have no hope of
convincing the child miracle on 34th
street anyone know no all right um
so uh because they're doomed to a life
of fear dominated by doubt anyways movie
quotes i could go on all night sorry
this is very rude of me
uh the point is if you don't change my
mind the idea that it's immoral
because you said i think once a country
establishes itself then they can
kind of shift towards socialism but not
full-blown socialism
so let me i guess frame it this way
i believe it's immoral to take some
something that you haven't earned
theft is the felonious taking of
something
that is not rightfully yours yeah okay
we would agree on it
okay so taking something that isn't
yours is immoral
i believe socialism is immoral because
it's theft now how does that change if
an economy is more stable or less stable
if it's that
exactly that i get where you're coming
from with that um
i think the thing the the the money
that's being redistributed
um sure is going towards things that
everybody can use
um because i honestly
like this is coming from i'm very left
on this issue not very but i'm pretty
left on this issue and i think welfare
is very abused
but i think it is needed um to some
extent and i think that i mean that goes
hand in hand
like a battered housewife who won't
leave her husband like okay i'll make
the road okay well yeah all right all
right
all right yeah it's abused but it's
needed that sounds pretty
you would understand that that sounds
like pretty dark people take advantage
of it
i would i would agree with you but i
think some people do need it i've met
like people that do
they do need it but i think there's i
mean i'm getting off track here but um
no no that's okay can i can i address
this because some people do need it and
i don't disagree with you that there are
people in this country who could use a
leg
exactly so people i would actually even
go let's remove the people who abuse
welfare
because we agree look common ground i
wish we it was that easy yeah i know but
i'm just going to remove that from the
argument because we already agree right
exactly let's talk about the people who
would actually let's say legitimately
need welfare
okay so people we would both agree on
i'm glad this is actually this is
productive about
discussion you don't call me a [ __ ] um
again let's let's take this as an
example you see because they really need
it
so let's say i uh let's use an example
of something i think
people could all agree on the kids with
cleft palates could probably use
the twenty dollars in my pocket far more
than i can right exactly yeah and there
are charities
that provide fixes yes exactly so
if you were to punch me in the face
repeatedly you know go bam bam bagel on
me and head butt me
and take my twenty dollars and give it
to a charity that helps kids with cleft
palates
would that be moral would it change the
fact that you bam bam bigelowed me into
no
no i mean that wouldn't but i mean the
process is much different than punching
somebody's face on socialism but
not all that different well yeah i
understand where you're coming from
totally that that definitely makes sense
um i think
so if we agree that something is immoral
and simply both agree theft is immoral
yeah i agree it doesn't change
regardless of the need yeah so it comes
down to
really you'd have to present the
argument to change my mind
here how socialism how the
redistribution
i see it as theft is in fact moral
because it seems like we're both
agreeing that it's not really moral yeah
yeah i definitely get where you're
coming from i'm glad you're um
i mean kind of changing my mind in a
sense hey
hey who was it yes thank you drew what
is that why aren't you talking this is
great
by the way you're changing my mind
because now i realize that far leftists
who write papers on socialists aren't
dicks
[Applause]
but can we agree all right so i would
say the u.s economy
make a rough estimate is around 80
capitalists and maybe
20 socialist just if you had to give
like percentages you know what
here's one thing i i don't know
percentages but i would agree with you
that certainly the united states as it
exists
today is not a true free market the
economy exactly we do have certain
culture states exactly
so my goal isn't to go even the majority
socialism it's just i think that a more
shift
maybe like get like a 30 70 60 40 you
know um
sixty percent capitalism that is in 40
socialism i just want
i don't want a full-on socialist i just
want a little bit you know a little bit
more like
more um more like taxing more
redistribution and it's not a full i'm
not
fully like sure socialist reform like
you know let's let's
overthrow like you know any sort of so
let's reduce kind of the comparison it
sounds to me like let's say instead of
punching me you pickpocketed me yeah i
wasn't looking so you didn't hurt me but
you still took the 20
and gave it to the kid with cliff
pallets that's the example of 6040
versus 80 20. yeah
is that any more moral because you think
it might be better
pragmatically speaking no yeah i agree
with you in that point um
have you heard there's there's uh i
guess we agree that yeah
socialism in is immoral the idea of
socialism it seems like we agree on that
as we define it yes um okay well i
appreciate that and if you want now
see look we agreed on something he said
maybe i'll concede this territory
and now i would like to give you an
opportunity since you're well spoken and
and very respectful
to go to the pragmatic i think that's
also an important component it doesn't
change the premise
but uh i would love to give you an
opportunity because i think you can
probably articulate it well um
uh so i think the hard part about
socialism also is
you're always gonna have um an [ __ ]
dictator that's gonna take over and try
to make it communist because he wants
you know he wants it all
um like bernie and jane sanders um
but oh that gets an ooh shut up
uh but there have been cases where they
have worked but it's on a very small
scale so like more talking small
communities
everybody knows each other you know like
like a lot of people don't feel bad you
know stealing from the poor guy if you
don't know him but like if you know like
the neighborhood like drunk you know
that that was just like a
uh i don't understand that was that was
the best that was bad that's like i
don't know
it has worked on very like very small
communities so that could give me some
examples of where socialism i guess
has outperformed what free enterprise
has created with america today because
that's the standard i'm using right
i come from a socialist province quebec
okay i wouldn't say an example of it
working very well yeah the french are
[ __ ] no there's definitely
there's definitely like very bad
examples i think venezuela was mentioned
earlier um
sure but i'm not going to talk about the
norway sweden that's that's already been
done
um but there let me ask you this
honestly before that guy left
were you planning on talking about
norway and denmark and sweden well my
friend
um has a girlfriend who lives in give me
a yes or no first
no actually i was i was i was more
focused on the percentages when i was
telling you about like okay
but um no he has a girlfriend in denmark
and
um i think the the cars sales tax is
like above 200
and that's outrageous to me i think
that's like yeah that's insane oh that's
one more thing actually i should i
should add it's very interesting because
probably if you wrote a paper on this
one thing too that people understand not
only is the income tax significantly
higher in the middle and lower class but
the value-added taxes these you know we
call them vat taxes here
those obviously impact consumers on a
scale which people would say you know
here in the united states bernie sanders
hillary clinton they're very much
against value-added taxes because
they negatively affect consumers and in
the middle class more than the
billionaires because how many yachts can
you buy
that's a huge component to the
centralized economy
in denmark well i think so i'm glad you
brought it up it's interesting yeah well
i yeah like i have firsthand experience
with this and i know that they i think
they have one car for their whole family
which is like
not heard of in america um but it
encourages public transportation more it
encourages more
i think more green we're not going to
talk that's
hold on a second encourage because
you're a very nice man
yeah if someone can't afford even a
piece of [ __ ]
car because of a 200 tax encouraged to
ride the subway
is a little bit of 80 of campus pretty
much i mean we all ride the bus
seriously that's because you're all poor
and don't work jobs yet
exactly um i'm guessing you guys aren't
necessarily
uh recreationally choosing urbana's
luxurious public transit
oh it's great i love it so again
discouraged so now we're talking again
about the government being a moral
arbiter of what behavior is acceptable
yeah that to me is immoral yeah no i
agree with that too okay
um yeah i don't know where i was going
there was that i was talking about like
the small colonies that working but i
just think it
it can never work on on such a large
scale like okay like
that's why i'm not for a total reform i
think it's just better just a little
shift that doesn't have to you know
i think just progress towards like a
more
even though you agree that it's
fundamentally immoral
i think to be totally socialist is
fundamentally immoral yeah
the pickpocket thing which i mean that's
a good way of putting it i agree with
that
um i just like pickpocketing isn't like
the same thing to me because i
i'm having a hard time articulating it
but i i understand you're
what you mean with the pickpocketing in
the the punching
and the punching and the kicking and the
screaming and that you're autistically
violent no yeah no socialism is violent
and that's why anywhere you see true
socialism
like you said turns yeah it runs it runs
into becoming a violent exact
regime very quickly which i think a lot
of it has the fact to do with military
um
um military and like dictator uh
interference well that's another a
couple okay two points now and then i'd
like to leave it here because i think
we've agreed on quite a bit
um two points that you just brought up
you said you know well i don't
necessarily know that it's immoral sorry
i know i'm touching your knees just
because i have to get the mic
is it kind of cute you're kind of cute
he was making eyes at you
so one thing we talk about you're like
well maybe kind of if we redistribute it
when we get to a certain point
let's just say you don't agree with the
pickpocketing or the punching example
this is something i've never and thomas
sol has talked about this i'm not
bringing anything new so please people
say i'm not ripping it off i know that
these are not new arguments i've never
understood why it is considered moral
for someone to take money from someone
else that someone else has earned
and i think maybe you can help me with
this but it's immoral for me to want to
keep
money that i've earned yeah no that
totally makes sense and
i think because that's what socialism is
yeah maybe my views will change when i'm
i'm making bank and i want anybody to
take you know
any money from me but but i mean
as of now i know what it's like to like
you know like be a college student a
poor college student
and have parents that like are helping
me pay through college and you know it
would just be nice to have
a little bit more of a break with that
kind of stuff you know
listen i agree with you i agree here's
the thing i agree with you and i would
actually like to see college be much
more affordable
um i would like to see you do very well
in this country and i do believe that
your views will change statistically
they're very likely to change
especially considering how open-minded
you are and how civil you've been um i
really really appreciate you sitting
down
very much and uh i just think
see this is a good example i'm glad we
broadcast this live would you say this
is probably a more productive discussion
great this is like i love having
conversations with people who have
different views of me but would you say
this is more productive than say like
yousef
oh i caught the tail into that but yeah
i mean from what i caught that was
probably more productive yeah the tail
end is a good way to describe it
um yeah i definitely feel like i don't
know you changed my mind on on some
aspects i feel like i also made you see
that like you know not everybody that's
kind of more left is just a bad person
well yes you you well i don't i don't
believe that everyone who's left is a
bad person
what i do believe is that you're you're
um i do believe your premise is
incorrect
and i do believe that then if we get to
the pragmatically speaking which we
didn't really get to because it sounds
as though you're kind of acknowledging
on a grand scale it couldn't work um i
just think it's important to leave this
conversation knowing that
i understand you want what's best for
america you understand that i want
what's best
we disagree and here i've given you
something to think about and i
appreciate you taking the time to do it
yeah definitely thank you drew i
appreciate it brother
someone's yelling at him someone's
someone's yelling at him
what what what max i don't know
don't don't come up behind me like that
all right someone's going to pat you
down max
[Music]
hold on a second oh
wait wait wait john pat johnny boyd him
down
this guy yells he's fine i'm gonna take
your word for it the guy who gave me the
pin
max nice to meet you max i appreciate it
yeah gosh you were just chomping at the
bit you just rudely elbowed some girls
and came right on in
i i i not mean to be rude or anything
i'm that's not me
okay all right well thank you well
i think now we're just saying names
no that would be socialism you can't
have my water right max
uh i believe that socialism is
fundamentally evil
right uh if you disagree and think you
can change and then by the way after
this we'll move on to another topic
who'd like to do actually in this
climate uh pro what no no
we're gonna do the gun topic pro gun
[Applause]
seems like a crowd of people who like
guns i know max but you can't take every
all right hold on calm down max sat down
so i believe that socialism is
fundamentally evil we don't have a ton
of time on this and we'll move on to
guns with someone else
change my mind um so i have some
reservations about it i would not
consider myself a full-on socialist
uh that being said nobody who sits down
by the way does hear that's what's so
interesting like everyone's kind of like
hedging their bets like
it's kind of like that friend in high
school who no one like you want to be
friends you want someone to be his
friend you wish that he had friends just
not you so you're like oh he's not
really my friend
full on but kind of that's socialism it
seems to everyone on this campus but i
think uh dismissing all aspects of it as
evil is guiding us away from some
important policies that can be enacted
okay well first up i haven't i haven't
uh disregarded all aspects of it i'm
talking about the premise the
fundamental premise
the ism of socialism right isms are
important right so i guess let's let you
define sorry i know i know it's not
ideal we just showed up and we
appreciate everyone who's here if you
can't hear me i apologize the stream
will be up online tomorrow
i really do apologize again thanks to
the security who did come here to make
sure we could do this tonight
and we will try and come back uh so
uh i disagree with the fundamental
premise for people who think
uh he said all aspects of socialism the
ism is what matters
right so socialism let's define that
we've done with everyone else how do you
define
socialism um so you know i wouldn't say
there's a concrete definition you know
talk to various people you get various
definitions
um i let's go with the dictionary so
right so
i guess you could argue that it is the
communalization of the means of
production the socialization of the
means of production
um hold on a second hold on a second
this is very important because and this
is one thing i know when i went to
college and i see them doing it more and
more
it's okay to say you would presume this
or maybe one might presuppose and talk
about your arguments and opinions
but there are certain things that aren't
arguments or opinions there are certain
things that are facts i think we have to
agree on that so
i i i can't go with you down that trail
if you say
i suppose you could argue that the
definition you just gave
if you could repeat it and say we agree
that socialism then we can have a
conversation because i'm not arguing
what do you believe socialism is
well you said you're not quite socialist
i want to know how you define it and you
just defined it in a way
and i think we would agree well so can
you redefine it okay sure
um i believe that socialist socialist
leading policies are ones that
uh attempt to socialize uh means of
wealth
um so means of production or
distribution wealth means production
okay those are those are your awards i
just want to make sure i i actually
socialism
right is the means of socializing or the
collective right
ownership taking or control of means
right of production or distribution
right correct
okay hold on we're gonna we're gonna
have something i just wanna make sure we
agree on that
okay and i am i believe that that is
immoral
definitely now remember you were sitting
down to change my mind right
so that's the premise that's not all the
tenants that's the ism we have grantees
and i believe it's immoral definitely
okay go ahead
um so what i wanted to say is that i
i think that you know blanketing these
uh these statements that social is
evil is driving our society away from a
couple beneficial policies
uh one of them i believe is a guaranteed
basic income
uh which is uh an economic system that's
been proposed by capitalists by
socialists
uh basically what it would do uh is it
would change the welfare state as we
know it
where everybody would be guaranteed a
certain amount of income
this would be around the poverty level
so guaranteeing everybody you know like
shelter food
clothing however uh it would create an
incentive for free market enterprise
uh at the same time and create an
incentive to work an incentive for
people to get out and okay and profit
i don't think i only was the only i
think he's just drunk on a thursday
okay can i address that yeah certainly
go ahead he said
he said i'm a communist yeah all right
okay i guess it probably i think he must
have been talking to you
um so here's one thing that you just
said i think it would be
to sort of eliminate this through the
idea that it's evil
would be to not acknowledge the virtues
i guess you said the beneficial economic
effects
economic benefits of socialism okay
again so
this is really important because it
comes back to the prince of the idea
that it's evil so
um for example many people in germany
argued especially after the treaty of
versailles they would say well hitler
was great for the economy
does that change that his idea of
national socialism
was immoral that's a total false
equivalency no it's not the idea is what
he did immoral if it had beneficial
effects for the economy
he blamed it on certain classes of
people that's not what's
that's not what people who promote
socialist policy so
who would you blame the inequality
problem on today well the inequality
problem is dealt by problems with
uh with i guess the
but the rich the upper class see it's a
different classism
hitler's you know we say the one percent
hitler said the jews
so um the point is no no it's not a
false equivalency
the point is if you if it doesn't change
the fundamental morality
i'm not vilifying of the policy
regardless of how beneficial it is
economically i'm not saying i'm not
saying it's rich people's fault
i'm saying that that's where you go
but before that the idea as you said
it's to deny the economic benefits
if the act that would drive economic
benefits for example
you're probably taught in school that
the united states was built on the backs
of slavery i don't
agree with that but you've been taught
that right
i mean that to some degree it's a touchy
subject i'm not going to get into it
okay
so people say you know let's let's agree
that the united states is let's say
built
the backs off of slavery right the
chinese built they were definitely
immoral as committed with slavery
i you couldn't agree okay so let's say
there are economic benefits to enslaving
people
there certainly are for some people it
still goes on across the islamic world
today it still goes on because there are
beneficial economic effects to certain
groups of people
does that change the fact of slavery is
immoral
i i'm kind of confused with how this can
relate back to the topic that we're
talking about let me be really clear
socialism is immoral okay
your point that's my only point and
you're you're here to change my mind
you're like well in this regard it's
immoral what if there's no
z but it does matter how do you get
socialism out of slavery
another point is they're both immoral
regardless of economic impact
the idea that the benefit of something
doesn't change its inherent morality we
use this example before
if i steal i can steal money and i can
use it to go get hookers and blow or i
can steal money and i can give it to
bono's charity which actually is a
horrible example because bono's charity
gives less than one percent of charity
but um but well it is that's what
socialism is
well i'm advocating for universal basic
income which is a socialist policy how
do you provide it
well you provide it by taxes how do you
get taxes
tax people's income how do you do that
the irs what if i don't want to pay
income taxes for universal income
i mean you go to jail you have to pay
taxes it's a
fact and that is
what do you want me to say to that that
is before that is the
forceful taking of something that you
have not earned that's the definition of
theft
you've just described fast which but
surely surely they're they're
i mean you talked about this with
someone earlier there there are there
are necessary goods that that need to be
provided
via taxes that wouldn't be provided
because of a free rider problem
in this case you can link that back to
the universal basic income and provides
goods that
that some people can't afford normally i
again we're going back i think you're
jumping around here and i i think we're
about out of time we're gonna do the gun
argument because if i
say that socialism is evil and you grant
that well maybe it is but some people
really need that theft to occur
what i'm saying well that is what you're
saying because you haven't so you don't
believe that
threatening someone with jail if they
don't pay additional taxes
it's not a deal to take their money
additional taxes it's overhauling the
welfare state system that we have in the
status quo
okay so what how much is enough wealthy
people in america today
pay about half what's the number what's
the moral number
the moral number of percentage that they
should pay
well i think it's important to audit
where our money's going first and then
evaluate
how much it would cost for a universal
basic income
after that you talk to the economist and
you decide what would be an appropriate
uh
income tax level to provide for a
universal basic income
yeah so i mean i i i'm not you have
those
numbers i'm not an economist so i don't
know i i haven't heard of any legitimate
economist who's argued that it would
work
but what was your name again i'm max max
i appreciate it max because again
we both agree on the premise you haven't
changed my mind as to the fundamentalism
of socialism thank you max i appreciate
you giving the floor to someone else
thank you
uh you know what now let's change this
to the uh the firearm argument the pro
gun change man we have that right
we have that banner yeah i don't know
who the radicals are are there radicals
here
hold on one second we are going to
change
over here what was that okay hold on i
got to buy nokia
in three minutes so we're gonna go with
uh the next topic i'm sure you've seen
this before who here is pro second
amendment
[Applause]
okay so pro second amendment this is one
obviously it's a hot topic right now uh
you have a lot of high schoolers who are
making the rounds
and uh i know it's unpopular to say
i don't think that people should be
determining policy certainly as it
relates to fundamental human rights on
an emotive response
regardless of whether they're 16 or 96
um i'm pro second amendment for those
who don't know i was raised in a country
where there is no second amendment
canada there is also no first amendment
so uh
when i came here i shot my first gun
first off i thought it was really cool
right kind of violates the principle of
civil dialogue and changed my mind
denigrating an entire nation of people
but the truth is canada is pretty silly
and so this is an issue right now that
is i think uh particularly for a lot of
people here uh particularly obviously as
we're talking about today here at the
school you know listen we want to do
this big this big show that we did like
at smu here and uh we can't do without
security to ensure the security of the
audience and the security of the venue
and this is also something before we get
into the second so it's very near and
dear to our heart because many members
of our team have had
restraining orders or they've had
serious security threats where uh i
won't say who but some of them do have
to carry
maybe i have to carry who knows i don't
know anyone here whether you have a
carry permit or not
isn't that isn't it the wonder of it
roll the dice let's see if you win the
lottery
um so it's an issue obviously it's near
and dear
to to my heart um and uh i i i also
think it's important to see kind of this
this
the bias by omission from the left that
you see on campus
it's one thing to just ban somebody on
campus and it's another thing to make it
impossible to bring in certain speakers
it's another thing to make it impossible
for people to come in and do what
they've planned to do
this right here is not ideal right it's
not
we yeah we wanted to bring in like an
smu had a fog machine and light shows my
half asian lawyer bill richmond who
knows bill richmond
[ __ ] bain showed up it's a lot of fun
it's a stage performance we want to be
the funnest party on campus
we could sven computer was there bp um
sven is an intern sven is working home
base to stream right now as a matter of
fact heist fan i think he's doing the
live tweeting
um but this is something that's
important the constant change and it
relates back to the second amendment
with the campus the reason that we did
this is because
we ran into a lot of roadblocks we knew
it couldn't be safe we knew we weren't
able to do the show we wanted to do last
minute i think we're gonna be doing it
at a
m if i'm not mistaken uh later in april
we'll be broadcasting that we already
taped some sketches and some segments
and have some guests booked uh but we
said you know what
rain or shine we're gonna show up anyway
this is what we can do
it's like that scene in fred's claws
where they make the hoo loops and the
baseball bats all that matters is that a
kid has a present to open up on
christmas that's what this
is we didn't want the fans to be screwed
we know it's not ideal but we appreciate
you showing up
and hey look we didn't get any rain so
i'm pretty sure that's a sign god hates
socialism
um and then as to the rules that change
that we talk about i'm sure plenty of
people have dealt with this with
facebook and twitter
and youtube they make up these new
violations and they change the rules and
you don't know how to play by them
because
there really are no rules that's what
happens when we often try to come on
come to campus that's all fun that
happens when we try to get
everything booked in advance the rules
change there was some miscommunications
here
so we appreciate the private security
detail who came out we appreciate the
one
officer who was willing to show up today
and that's the same thing yeah
i'm sure illinois unions have nothing to
do with that if you show up to the lotto
with crowder event you'll meet the brass
knuckles
um i don't know why urbana sounds like a
guy from new jersey i have no idea
um that's what happened with the second
amendment right we see that a lot
what do they say these are the
ever-changing rules and so i think the
premise is important what the second
amendment is
what it ensures otherwise you get into
the territory of
oh no one wants to take your guns away
no one wants to and now do we see we saw
justice stevens say let's repeal the
second amendment
right i know and everyone's trying to
blame like yeah that's a conservative
thing because he has an r next to his
name how many people here don't care if
someone has an r next to their name
it comes down to what your principles
are
oh shall not be infringed yeah i
appreciate it thanks for yelling out uh
i can't really hear you guys that well
so if i ignore some of your yells i did
hear canada sucks that one was loud and
clear
i think they heard you in nova scotia um
so i think it's important this is why we
go back to the fundamental issue
as we talked about earlier i appreciate
you it's like nothing up my sleeves you
can see these notes here on
you know what here one second you guys
want to do an exercise before i can't
show this to all of you
but what's your name what's your name
demi debbie debbie
would you mind sitting down to be real
quick i know you're a fan real quick
so we're going to go to second amendment
oh shoot sorry i just spilled
shoot i've got water all over myself so
this is what we have written down as you
can see here kind of in red while some
of these are in black
are the claims that they might make uh
and can you give me a favor
these are arguments that are very
commonly made by the left so it doesn't
take
doesn't take a genius you just have to
know the branch and then kind of the
sticks that go off from the branch now
guess what you don't get off the branch
if they can't convince you that theft
that socialism
is somehow moral sorry are you cold i
know i wish i had hand warmers i'm
freezing
um that being said we have these
arguments oh you do it
yeah so let's be careful let's just no
no no that's okay thank you i appreciate
it you're in a t-shirt you want to show
that you do gracie jiu-jitsu i
appreciate it but
what do you blue bell purple belt okay
good for you um can you
do me a favor just so you guys can kind
of see this i don't think we've heard
anything today
debbie debbie debbie that uh we weren't
already prepared for this is something
that's a fundamental difference between
the right and the left
it is very easy to prepare why why is it
easy to prepare
well because what did i do i looked at
what your professors here on campus say
and by the way it's the exact same when
you go back to marx to bernie sanders
you go all the way to the media when
they talk about democratic socialism
there's nothing new now it doesn't mean
that you shouldn't prepare yourself for
every possibility
but all i have to do is look at what
your professors say and we heard that
parroted today so can you do me a favor
here let's just read kind of this like
these claims so people can kind of see
we won't go through the rebuttals but
we'll just see the claims that we
anticipated today
sure the top 0.1 percent have as much
wealth as the bottom 90
or any variant of that stat this income
inequality is outrageous
and immoral now of course i wrote it as
a more angry liberal
uh but we did we saw us run into that
the idea of inequality that that's more
immoral than socialism well guess what
we were prepared for that
and actually even agreed with drew that
that's not fundamentally immoral
um this one here you saw socialist
countries like denmark sweden i don't
think we actually had the
the corporation argument here uh let's
see what else we got
uh so okay let's read this one so what
if it costs a lot universal healthcare
is way better in other countries
you're reading it like andy kaufman
reading the great gatsby you're very
enthusiastic he's like
he's better in other countries i
appreciate it uh we didn't hear someone
bring that up but we didn't hear people
bring up the virtues of socialized
healthcare
uh one thing there that's really easy by
the way
really really easy when people say
universal health care in other countries
because now we've gotten off the moral
argument keep bringing them back to well
on a second
if if hitler provided universal health
care i'm not comparing bernie sanders to
hitler but i'm saying if you use
nationalist socialism to provide health
care for a certain nation of people does
that change the fundamental immoral act
of that ill-gotten gain it doesn't but
even then when we get to the pragmatic
results we write this here actually we
have um
these stats but you don't need all these
stats for example 45
more likely to die in british hospitals
emergency rooms you can see here nine
hours
in canada the united states it's two
hours i dealt with that one as a kid
you don't need those stats there's one
stat you need to know when it comes to
universal health care
the only example that the left can point
to of universal healthcare working
better
is our subjective polling methods where
people are asked if they are satisfied
with their level of health care
well it's just like with college kids
here if someone gave you a crappy 2002
kia
and you'd been riding the champagne
illinois bus for weeks you would think
that that was awesome if someone said
you like your car you'd probably say yes
right
yeah now that being said someone who has
a five-year-old cadillac and is ready
and is able to afford something better
and wants to
they would have a different standard so
the only stat that leftists point to or
i would say
i don't want to say only because well
there's this one in this colony with
these
these tribes let's move that the main
step that's pointed to and i would
question your professors on this when
they say universal health care works
better in these other countries
now we've gotten away from the moral
argument we've gotten away from the
economic nationalism that you see in
these countries
you're talking about subjective
standards because objectively
longer wait times are not better
objectively higher mortality rates are
not better
objectively your chances of dying from
some kind of a serious illness or not
getting care are not better objectively
the standards are not better
subjectively they're better be prepared
for that
and know that because it's the most
common argument i see and i see so many
conservatives going well i guess i
didn't know that
i guess i didn't know that cuba had
better health care did you see that and
michael morsicko for a perfect example
he claimed cuba had better health care
than united states why
because they thought it was better they
said do you like your health care more
and they said yes we think it's better
but it's not
all right do we need it are you you're
wait don't insult this is a family show
okay here's one i think we ran into a
few times can you read this claim right
here sure
we already have many socialist policies
in the u.s public roads
maroons police military
do you want to abolish those as well
what's the harm of adding more
free health care nothing up my sleeve so
see how many i think all three of us
all three arguments run into that right
yeah this is what this is what we call
really a false equivalency now how does
that work how do you prepare yourself
for and that's what we're going to be
printing these
booklets hopefully you know any mug
clubbers here the more people who join
mud club the more we'll have time to
print them out
um and money to do so we're going to
self-publish that
again this is a false equivalency you
need to know the difference between
a public good as we discussed right and
a commodity
once you define that that's why it's so
important to define your terms what is
socialism
what do i mean by evil what is a public
good
what is a commodity what's the
difference when you get down to the
definition andrew breitbart was a man
who actually coached me it was just a
stand-up comic
thank you very much yeah he was a great
great guy great guy um i'm done with
breitbart the man not the trademark just
the man i knew him personally was a
tremendous guy i can't say enough good
things about him
and by the way very flawed as well as
many great people are you look at the
story of churchill i would certainly
say he's comparable in the war on new
media he always talked about knowing
your definitions because if you say
well one could argue that socialism is
don't let them do that
because then guess what now they can say
well hold on that's just what one
definition no no let's define what it is
and let's discuss that do not allow the
conversation to go
on undefined not only is it no longer
productive you'll just begin talking in
circles and it becomes a cable news
sound bite gotcha game
but it's also just a way to not be able
to make a constructive argument it's
just not helpful
and sometimes you end up looking stupid
because you haven't defined what it is
so um there we go that was actually
that's all we have here on on the
socialism so what would you say you say
that
pretty much all the arguments we heard
were right here in this booklet yes no
there you go
debbie 99.5 in your opinion
okay just like the 80s 95 299
all right what are you like it's like
matthew broderick in the computer war
tennis shoes he's just
like spend computer bp 95 and by the way
we also have as you can see we have
death rates here all these sources which
would be
in the change of mind book when we
release it debbie do you have any any
question we're going to go on to the
second amendment thing but i appreciate
you uh watching my back there and i
appreciate helping me out with this is
there anything else you have to say are
you good
can you follow me on twitter i will
follow you on twitter what is your
twitter
uh debbie bernal debbie bernal everyone
here follow debbie on twitter get me for
now
oh and by the way if i can ask you guys
everyone here has a smart device the
stream is live on youtube and facebook
if everyone here could take out your
smartphone
and make sure to tweet out the hashtag
change my mind
and crowder illinois takeover which was
not self-titled but i think it's pretty
uh
i'll go with it um i appreciate it
you can take a selfie yes debbie because
you you assisted so well thank you
so everyone follow debbie everyone
retweet the stream you guys are
fantastic
spell bernard bernal b-r-n-e-l
b-e-r-n-a-l
debbie bernal okay no creepy don't no
one anthony weiner that i can see
already people
lifting their jacket taking the space
odyssey angle
sick puppies all of you all right so i
am pro second amendment this is a hot
button issue today
uh i guess we don't really need this the
social is socialism is evil
uh i'm pro second amendment change hold
on one second let's uh knock it jared
or someone we need someone just to give
him give him a cheque
[Applause]
make data great again okay silicon
valley fan
all right let's go bring him on let's
what's your name sir
kart karvik
karthik sit down karthik nice to meet
everyone give it a give a hand for
karthik sitting down here
no you don't get to take the microphone
as well that's
that's very college student of you my
microphone
but you didn't earn it i'm kidding um
so okay i am pro second amendment uh i
support the second amendment
wholeheartedly
uh it seems to me that you disagree if
you do i'm willing to hear your
arguments and have my mind changed
sure so um i just want to clarify i
don't necessarily disagree with the
second
amendment itself all right you don't
disagree yeah you don't disagree with
the second amendment
certain implementations of gun policy
itself
no it doesn't it doesn't work it doesn't
work if we say well first off what do we
agree on the second amendment to mean
and this is something we see a lot you
see a lot when people come up and
they're
they're a little bit more confident and
then people see some discussions kind of
unravel the way they did and they go
well i'm not really a socialist i'm not
really against the second amendment i'm
against
gun policy implementation is what you've
said now it doesn't work for me but
let's go along that trail um first off
what do you believe the second amendment
to me
i mean i believe it's the right to bear
arms regardless of
whatever type of gun i know you're gonna
have to have you speak out karthik
okay sorry you can yell at me it's okay
just don't call me autistic can you hear
me
[Applause]
yes
i i believe that the second amendment is
i mean it's the right to bear arms that
can include any type of gun
okay but i think from a policy
standpoint right
can you guys can you guys hear them
car's like you have to speak up or we
can't do this
okay so i believe that from a policy
standpoint we have to regulate certain
types of guns or just certain types of
situations
to account for certain external karthik
you're very nice but your
your voice is like white noise i need we
need to hear you
i i'm not saying i don't i don't i don't
want to give you the boot but if they
can't hear you we can't have the
conversation absolutely
okay so i really believe that there we
go you're starting to hear him yeah
good good i'm sharing you karthik
they're rooting for you over me go sound
off like you got a pair so i believe
that there
i i believe that there are certain
situations where the government has to
step in to account for certain
externalities that might exist
within you know whether or not that's
the economy or the society so
from a certain standpoint i agree that
we should you know be very
well i use this term light lightly but i
believe we should be very liberal in
terms of
the type of guns we allow in the uh just
in the society i just think that we have
to place certain
regulations to provide certain cities so
so i i'll i'll get into that
right so well what matters most is you
said the second amendment
the second amendment is the right to
bear arms you said period yes okay
so what matters is also the why why
i mean i believe that it's to you know
prevent against like an oppressive
government
yes yes for well both internal and
external threats so we would both agree
on that yeah
okay good because actually they're often
not teaching that in schools so i
appreciate that you actually acknowledge
that okay the second amendment is to
protect ourselves
from a tyrannical government
historically understand why that exists
and you said that should include we
should be very liberal including
most firearms and now you've said
certain externalities so that's
the reason why is it's and by the way we
would both have to agree it's amendment
number two
in our constitution it's a fundamental
human right yeah absolutely
okay so now i'd like you to go on with
why and when we should strip people of
their human rights
sure so i from my general understanding
there are two major problems with guns
and i don't think that
mass shootings in general is i mean i i
think
can you guys hear karthik okay okay okay
okay okay okay
so so i i don't know
okay so
yeah so i i don't believe that mass
shooting so
i i don't believe that mass shootings
are the problem that we have to be
looking at
because when we look at gun violence the
problems that i see are gang violence
and like gun related shootings related
to suicide right
so these are the real problems that i
think i see with gun gun deaths gun
violence right now
so i think these are the externalities
that we have to try to account for
now so you mean for example you talk
about gang violence
so externalities uh like crime
yeah yeah sorry now you guys got him
nervous he's literally eating the mic
jerks like crime right absolutely so we
should outlaw crime
no i look i i agree no i think that we
do need to
i think we need to like attack this from
a standpoint okay
let's stop doing this what changes would
you make the second amendment or what do
we need to do differently because i
don't want to walk around in circles
here especially when people get your
second amendment right now gives me the
right to keep and bear arms to protect
myself against a tyrannical government
or someone kicking in my
door or for all of the above what
problem do you have with it
so i think just as an addendum to the
second amendment right
and this is going to be very very
unpopular right but i believe that i
think we need gun registry
i think we need to keep a tally on who
has guns
and and hold on i believe this because i
think it can actually aid in law
enforcement
right you can actually create risk pools
so where gun violence is likely to occur
based on you know how many suicides have
occurred in a certain uh
in a certain area right okay so if you
have a gun registry you can actually
tally that data yeah and you can create
forces i appreciate i appreciate taking
time karthik that's where we're going to
end this one appreciate it give it up
for karthik everybody it's hard to hear
him
and i the only reason i'm doing this is
because there's no way hold on a second
hold on a second hands down
there's no way you can go wherever you
want or you can hang around but there's
no way that
that my mind will be changed on this
because we just talked about okay the
second amendment what it is it's a
fundamental human right
to defend against a tyrannical
government and this is one thing that
kind of happens at the left it's a
circular feedback loop
what's the solution to give the
government the ability to know
exactly who has guns when they have guns
where they have guns
why to empower the police force keep in
mind
the left today as we know them of course
as today's social movement these are the
people who believe that police officers
are off
you know offing black kids in record
numbers just because of the melanin in
their skin
so to say that we acknowledge that the
second amendment is a fundamental human
right
to defend against a tyrannical
government would fly in the face of the
idea of a gun registry and if you look
at this you look at the australian
buyback that people often point to
you look at what's happened in places
where there are gun registries yes it is
used directly to infringe upon people's
human rights
which is the entire purpose of the
second amendment in the first place
i just didn't want to continue down that
track i know you guys couldn't hear him
i don't think it's a particularly
convincing argument the
second here gun registry uh i'm not on
board but yeah this guy good to go
go go ahead you have a gun registry in
the state of illinois
[Music]
well then don't be so upset when i
insult illinois gosh
all right sorry go ahead i'm pro will
your name again
jordan jonah jonah nice to meet you i am
pro's second amendment
appreciate it uh changed my mind i can't
you guys have a gun registry in illinois
okay and it doesn't work in the south
side of chicago i can tell you yeah i
was going to say
you guys okay all right guys guys guys
guys this isn't gangs of
this isn't gangs of new york okay mr
dead rabbits
these aren't the four corners everyone
just calm down jonah is here
we want him to be calm collected i am
pro second amendment i appreciate you
taking the time to sit down
thank you very much i appreciate it you
look like that kid that actor who's in
the black donnelly's you ever seen that
show i have not there was a film i think
called the ruins
by the way can people hear me all right
i think it's a big issue all right
sounds good it was a pretty big shift
they can't hear you you know obviously
then i can't hear it's hard to have an
argument i guess right a discussion or
discussion whatever you want to call it
sure well honestly
saying oh no no no no this isn't an
argument
i want to be really clear i think we've
had some really really productive
discussions with several different
people today
i mean i don't think that i don't think
that there's necessarily a negative
connotation
i wouldn't give a negative connotation
in this context with with an argument
but
this this is beating around the bush
discussion fine okay okay so your second
pro second amendment right
yes okay and as we as you just said
let's let's define what second amendment
is purpose and
i totally agree with you it's too well
let's read it actually
good appreciate it i don't have notes i
can go
at the internet you know no and listen
by by the way
i i haven't i'm not using them people
keep keep an eye on this i'm not using
the notes so i would like i would love
to uh for you to read the second
amendment well
russian collusion jonah i would like for
you to read the sec don't worry that
they're just
they're just rambunctious because they
didn't get trannybane out here um
if you can read the second amendment for
me i would appreciate it a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
[Applause]
on a second one thing one thing one
thing hold on calm down
guys guys come on come on i have a
discussion if if i can't speak right
yeah i know but you've seen i'm doing my
best but i i i i get to do this they're
going to listen to me they're probably
not going to listen to you
that's great they love america okay so
you just read the second amendment
wonderful
and so so we both still agree on what it
is yes and like let's just clarify it
right so
it is the right to keep and bear arms to
protect yourself against
foreign and domestic threats including
including the government
thank you appreciate it so let's
let's do that the implications of that
statement are i want to tank i'm gonna
i should i should be able to go buy me a
tank right now yeah would you agree with
that state
here's what's ironic about that
statement um
first off tanks are allowed in europe
which is very interesting to me
and uh are you aware of uh madison's
letter of mark and reprisal
i'm not okay so this is a letter
actually giving
the it was a letter issued to a private
ship said hey are we allowed to have
cannons on this ship to protect from
pirates and madison said the second
amendment
of course you are so we say that cannons
are at least similar
to a tank back then it was the most
basically advanced weaponry you could
have
well so so let me give this let me
make sure i understand what you're
saying you're saying that back in the
day
you could get not just musket but you
said you can get a a
cannon a cannon yes yes yes i'm saying
that yes back in the day the second
amendment covered
yes all are all small arms all
individual arms that could be used
defensively yes so you're saying that i
should be able i'm 18
should i be able to go buy a tank
because that was that is that is that
what you're saying
[Applause]
and a fighter jet too okay first off i
know you brought up the constitution why
don't we do this let's let's bring up do
me a favor bring up the definition
of arms right here no but um
can i can i grab them okay no they look
pretty nice they look pretty nice all
right
i mean arms no no i'd like you to bring
it up if you bring out the constitution
i'd like you to bring up the definition
of arms
um to make sure that we're not going on
down a rabbit trail or maybe we disagree
whereas we might
search up arms right i'm going to get
and get arms as in
well no search up arms i'm sure miriam
webster smart
smart smart document there it'll give
you the definition of arms
i just since i'm not using reference you
know i just think it's i just i'm asking
you to because i don't think it'd be
fair
i will say the one part about uic i
can't stand is the wi-fi is terrible
that's the only part well
anyway it's not quite working here but
anyway
it's not it's not bringing up arms it's
not can someone bring up the definition
of arms again because i just okay who
has the definition of arms as it relates
to weaponry
you said you had it you're like that kid
in class like i have the answer at the
answer so you want to stand up
i forgot my answer okay arms
okay do you want to read that for me
thank you knocking jared
[Applause]
weapons and ammunition armaments okay
weapons and ammunition armaments
okay and then it says underneath that
includes a list
let's see weapons firearms guns
uh artillery ordinance yeah
well you know the the last kid said this
do you want a society because i mean the
second amendment right
there the whole point of why we have a
court right why we have a judiciary is
to interpret what that means right no
and what the implications are
really so you don't think that the
courts were in it
were the founding fathers that made the
judiciary to interpret the constitution
to interpret our laws
and those implications to ensure the
authenticity and the implementation of
the constitution
that's why i think we would both have a
problem with activist judges on either
side
activist judges i mean there it's it's
supposed to be an inherently
non-political position that's obviously
not the case
right but but certainly like you know
the lifetime uh
appointments right so you you'll have
both judges on both sides
but but forget about that first let's go
let's go back to your things i don't
want to get you off topic and i don't
want you to think that i'm being unfair
let's go to the uh judiciary decision
the most recent of which is
um i'm not quite sure dc versus heller
okay
i'm not familiar with dc versus heller
well that's the most that that who
well that's the most fundamental second
amendment case in modern history
so this is actually where we went down
and uh there were dissenting voices that
lost so uh the second amendment is
currently as it is interpreted and it's
interpreted as a way that you and i just
agreed upon
which is people have the right to keep
and bear arms period so
this was up uh helen versus uh helen
brothers say helen keller i always get
heller versus dc
what's really important there is you
talk about the judiciary because now
we're talking about interpretation of
the second amendment
so let me be really clear before because
i want to then i'll let you know what
the judiciary interpretation was of the
second amendment
what's your interpretation of the second
amendment
well as i said i i said it when we first
started
okay good so i agree but but i guess i'm
saying right like
the first amendment then where's the
disagreement then i guess we can okay so
we can limit the first amendment no
no what is libel right like no see
that's different libel slander those are
all limitations on your freedom of
speech in the same way
second amendment right so incorrect but
continue
come up here like so so right so i don't
believe that i should be able to go buy
uh a tank per se okay and i
would say that's that's that's that's
promotion of general welfare
that's that's domestic tranquility right
so that that like i think that the
government has a variety of purposes and
i know you might i know you believe in a
small government that's fine
but there are inherent purposes in
having a government that's why we have a
country that's why it's we're not agree
on that
okay fine so so in my mind the
government
should and ought to limit certain things
for example i should not be able to buy
a tank
but but actually what if this is your
opinion yeah what i would what i would
really like to get back to is
i mean do you can you can you can one
favorite i don't want to
could you do me a favor because you just
kind of jumped around to a bunch of
different things the first amendment
um first off yeah like you went through
libel and slander two very different
things and they're illegal by the way
for different reasons which do not
infringe upon the first amendment
just like when people use the argument
yelling fire in a crowded theater it's
the call to action libel or slander is
actually something that is designed to
hurt somebody
one in the written form one in the
spoken form which is
untrue so what you're effectively suing
for is it's a crime because it causes
damages in a very tangible way that is
fundamentally untrue
it's not it's not about freedom of
speech you can say anything you want you
can right now say anything you want you
can you can yell out right now that i'm
a dick
i don't disagree on that yeah okay yeah
thank you very much so you can and i
just
i'm not suing you there are no damages
there okay for example so let's show you
because you just jumped around and said
the limitations of the first amendment i
agree and there are
friends stay on top so let's go back to
the second amendment now the second
amendment we agreed
on it but now you're saying there are
limitations as they need to be in you
that need to be interpreted judicially
correct
well i'm saying i'm saying i think often
times you will hear conservatives
take this extreme approach where whereby
they would say
oh okay let's talk about like right now
right people are people are trying to
you know ban semi-autos or et cetera
there's a whole bunch of things bump
stocks the whole thing right
and and this appeal the second amendment
well let's not talk about that right
because that's not what all
liberals think that we should repeal the
second amendment many of them do
i don't know if that's true i mean where
are you where are you getting that like
well
in theory repealing the first amendment
that's what you just did you know i did
not say let's repeal the first amendment
i had no point when you say let's put
limitations we can put limitations on
the freedom of speech
we currently cannot do that that is
fundamentally altering the first
amendment call it an addendum as opposed
to repeal
i'm saying libel and again let's get
away from the first amendment
my point is what's your problem with the
second amendment let's get to this
you're talking about what is your
problem
as we both agreed it to be and then
we'll move on from here conservatives
often
will say i want my high capacity
magazine because when and
when the government ultimately
ultimately becomes tyrannical and that's
up for debate but
sure fine uh uh under the assumption
that all governments become tyrannical
that you are no no no no okay hold on a
second this is something that we
that you can't do i know you came in you
said looking for an argument i think
because you
are you more of an argumentative person
i i mean i don't i don't know quite how
to answer i'll say yes
uh because what you just did was you
presumed my premise
you said most conservatives and then you
brought up something that most
conservatives do not believe
and then you said all the assumption
that all governments become tyrannical
so these are presumptions that you're
making that i didn't make so what i
wanted to do
is avoid that and i talk about this a
lot anyone who follows the program i've
not assumed your motive
i've not assumed your position the
reason for for picking our terms and our
definition here
it's not trickery it's the opposite of
it because i don't want to assume your
position i want to hear your position
so your position in the second amendment
your problem with it
as you agree as you've agreed with me it
to be
again so let me explain i say i'm saying
oftentimes i hear conservatives
say is that better well no you said all
governments becoming tyrannical so but
what is your problem with the second
amendment so i'm getting there
okay my my problem with it's not even so
much
my pro so my problem with the second
amendment is how conservatives
talk about it and then not follow
through on their logical
premise so what i get so i guess what
i'm saying is
oftentimes guys don't don't shut them
down okay listen you guys here
let's let's have this conversation i
think it's more productive if we can
hear what he has to say
uh and i appreciate him sitting down i
appreciate your your enthusiasm but
let's let's let him go
i'm saying oftentimes i hear
conservatives say oh i need a i need an
ar-15
i need a high-capacity magazine because
i need to be able to protect myself from
the government right which is the
purpose of the second amendment
and so then i'm gonna say okay so in
order to fully protect yourself from the
second amendment
you ought to have a tank is that what
you're saying and i think that's kind of
an absurd
that is not what i'm saying i'm not
saying in order to protect you ought to
have a tank that's not what i'm saying
okay so it let's say the military all of
a sudden tomorrow
turns he wants to take over the
government do a coup d'etat whatever
then they'll come come stroll into your
house and and do whatever they want
right because they have a tank and you
can shoot them with your semi-automatic
weapon but like
the tank's going to win no
no you'll go with an ar-15 over a tank
right like that's ridiculous
no no hold on everyone everyone's quiet
no um
i'll go with an entirely armed citizenry
over a government
with a registry able to take their guns
away so hold on a second here you just
made a bunch of presumptions no i'm not
saying you ought to own a tank
seems to me your problem is with
conservative interpretation of the
second amendment and so what you use to
substantiate that
is what i think you guys if anyone takes
philosophy in college this reverse
nirvana fallacy
so you're talking about an imbalance of
power the government has tanks
right so you're allowing this
presumption to
let's say this this theory this the
philosophical portion of this equation
the government let's say became
tyrannical okay
sure you're saying if it became the
purpose of the second amendment right
you're saying there's potential let's
agree with that so you're saying if they
perchance became tyrannical they would
have this incredible advantage because
they'd have tanks
not to mention drones nukes and your
solution to this imbalance in power
is to create an even an even greater
discrepancy in power
oh so so i see what you're saying and
and that makes sense but i get i guess
my point is
i take an ar-15 over nothing i take 300
million americans with an ar-15 over a
tank
and i certainly would take my
fundamental human right to own one over
someone else's opinion
say that again i didn't hear that last
part and i certainly would take my
fundamental human right over someone
else's interpretive opinion of
it so this doesn't change the fact of
none of us have disagreed it doesn't
change the fact as to what the second
amendment is
but again yes if you look at afghanistan
you look at guerrilla warfare you look
at for example switzerland with world
war ii
armed citizens it is it absolutely is a
deterrent we know it's true
it was neutral in world war ii no
switzerland was neutral world war two
but switzerland every person was armed
geographically and because of an armed
populace if you look at documentation
that was a big part
that allowed them to be neutral you read
about the japanese talking about the
americans where they didn't want to get
into a land war
that was ridiculous i'm sorry all right
you actually think that a military
is if you yes i do
well i guess then we have a very
fundamental misunderstanding that you
think a military is scared
of the u.s population because they are
uh well armed
be quiet i'm talking right like calm
down like settle
down we can have a good experience
here's the reason they're doing it
they're getting upset because you're not
being very civil when you presume things
that i didn't
say okay so none of this changed what
the second amendment is
uh pragmatically speaking absolutely of
course i do believe that an armed
citizenry
versus a tyrannical government is far
better than a completely disarmed
citizenry i know you disagree there but
yeah i think that that's better overall
and it doesn't change the fact that i
have a fundamental human right in this
country to self-protection
regardless of your opinion so the reason
i ask you this because your problem has
been with the interpretation from
conservatives as you said of the second
amendment i'm gonna
have to wrap it up here okay so this is
my this is this is my issue i have a
problem
with the leftists the liberal
interpretation of the second amendment
and that goes back to when i asked you
before
about heller versus dc because we're
talking judicially the supreme court
do you know what the dissenting opinions
the opinions on your side of the ledger
were for
uh their view of the second amendment
well i don't but i know that new york in
new york state right so there's there
was a there was another one
i'm going to give you that and then and
then i appreciate it was was it uh jonah
jonah thank you very much
let me let's let's give a round of
applause for jonah i appreciate it
because i would encourage people to look
up new york state
uh rifle and pistol association versus
cuomo okay
thank you ar-15s were not protected
under the second amendment
okay i appreciate it um but i would like
you to look up i appreciate it i would
like you to look up heller versus dc
and this is so important because heller
versus dc it's not so much
by the way we we have an interpretation
of the second amendment as we know it
today
now jared how long have we been doing
this an hour and a half all right
this is actually going to be the last
one so thank you to jonah i want to i
want to leave it on this
uh because this is really important
we've talked about this quite a bit i
actually have written down actually i
would have you come and look at this to
see if we can corroborate it but
um you know what the truth is i don't
even know that actually do you want
debbie to come on back out
[Applause]
debbie bernal come on back out i think i
have it do you have it
i think hold on a second debbie i don't
know where this is there's two genders
changed my mind
male privilege is a myth changed my mind
pro gun is somewhere back here
debbie you want to talk while i do this
to buy time who wants to hear from naked
jared jared say something
[Applause]
everybody just want to thank everyone
again for coming out
uh we're not wrapping up here but just a
big shout out
that's a fun one everyone coming and
supporting us and
[Music]
you're worse than karthik sound off like
you've got a pair
rebrand use this one's great
see now you see what happens when i give
him control of the mic
no give it up for knocking he's the guy
who made all this happen i came out here
[Applause]
okay so debbie i want to sit down by the
way don't take any pictures because
we're going to sell it's only for five
dollars but come on
you guys can't just steal the
intellectual property that's another
argument does an intellectual property
actually exist and where does it
infringe upon the rights of physical
property
changed my mind um okay so something
that uh
i i find uh interesting actually here he
surprisingly did no one brought up the
mass shootings argument
um we have an overall kind of strategy
that i write down i have a brilliant
researcher named reg
uh who helps me and we prepare we sit
down and kind of do mock debates through
every scenario listen by the way
i'm showing you this to show you i'm not
some skilled i'm not like a ben shapiro
i'm not this brilliant i'm not a thomas
soul
i'm a comedian who happens to have a
platform and i'm so humbled and grateful
for it
and uh i'm just hoping that i can help
you guys go forward so you can have
these conversations
and actually change people's minds
that's one thing that naked jared and i
will say you know when we went out we
did change my mind the first time we
thought there's no way this is going to
be a hit
because i had been on fox news for four
and a half years and they were always
like sound bite kid sound bite you know
if you can that's why
al sharpton just made things rhyme
before he has the stroke on the
teleprompter we would sit down and do an
hour conversation
and it was just what tens of millions of
plays i don't know how many it's been
one of our most successful segments
because
it tells me that there's a craving for
truth out there right now
that people want to see something raw
they want to see something real
and it surprised us it overwhelmed us
and so it's unbelievable that we're able
to do this and people will listen
and i do hope that it's productive and i
want more people to go out we see people
sending in pictures with change my mind
booths
we appreciate it and so eventually we're
going to do the book yeah it's a meme
now too p
is stored in balls i know bring
it please continue memeing me so we have
some strategies here david says that
where we kind of write down overall this
will be in the book when we sell it
uh make them define their terms make
them determine what the second amendment
is
make them substantiate their claims uh
this case no one really actually had any
change in the second amendment but ask
for their solution
determine exactly where their line is
have some positive this is something
very important
have positive solutions to offer right
but i want to see uh the last claim that
he made was
you think you should be able to have a
tank i believe right
hold on let's see let's see where this
is because i believe
that this is in here somewhere hold on a
second
uh one second okay here you go let's
read this claim right here
debbie bernal okay okay
so you say we need guns to resist
tyranny
do you seriously think that you could
resist the us government with your own
guns
yes that is the exact argument that we
just heard correct
and this is exactly what we talked about
uh this is a reverse nirvana fallacy
it's this idea of well we already live
in a society where there's this
discrepancy in power where the
government has so much power
so the solution i don't know it's so
illogical to me the solution should be
to strip the people who are already less
powerful of the power they currently
have
it doesn't stand to reason does the
argument hold water
it does not it doesn't hold water and
that's what the socratic method is i've
talked about this quite a bit debbie
anything else you want to peruse or read
or
no demi everybody follow me so much
oh hold on a second all right so we are
going to get going pretty soon here uh
and that's well thank you very much i
appreciate it like i said hopefully next
time we come into
urbana we bring one depaul
how many of you here will make the trip
out to depaul for a full auto car ride
with the kick-ass fog machine the light
show the security
uh we just did smu by the way we have
been we're so grateful and so humbled
we've been grossly underestimating
the audiences that show up as we did
here today this is last minute it was
planned yesterday
um with mcfarland auditorium at smu we
had to turn away people in a 2500 seat
auditorium
just making sure that the exits there
are secure
required i think 18 25 police officers
and so we're really trying to get
everything up to snuff here we actually
specifically for you guys just so you
know
specifically because of the
miscommunications that fell through and
security not uh
being as helpful as we would have liked
them to and specifically because we
weren't able to get in and bring in our
equipment
we bought a shitty news van slash bus
to equip so when things like this happen
we can an emergency drive across the
country and get to you guys faster
that way we can actually broadcast from
the band
we will broadcast from the van on the
side of the road
if we have to we'll find a place this is
the deal we've talked about
this is no longer just coming to play
nice this is intellectually
a hostile takeover we are coming to your
campuses
period whether you ban us or not we're
going to find a way we'll be right near
the campus
we want to come in and do a lot of
earthquake it's a comedy show we want to
do the same shows that liberals are able
to do on campus
we want to come in and make it
entertaining for you guys so everyone
can have a night of laughs and escape
for a little bit
but if we're not allowed to if they
start putting up these roadblocks
we'll just get in a bus and drive up
anyway because
you guys
and i say this i'm hunched over here i
feel like the bfg
you guys this is genuinely about
everyone out here and i appreciate
everyone here being respectful and not
shouting anyone down
this is not about uh the police officers
on campus this is not about the college
republicans this is not about me it's
not about naked jared
it's about the audience here the fans
people out there who crave truth
who who want to walk in the light of
truth right now on campus and i know
it's hard i know it's time
i get i had an email here today this is
something
i don't i hate to end it on it on a
dollar note but it's happened at smu
um can i can i kind of talk about this
is a little bit a little bit kind of
sensitive
this kid sent an email uh today he
talked to me and i gave him uh an email
to send it to
and this is not to be self-aggrandizing
it's because i think not gerry would
agree we've realized the responsibility
that we have
and that's why everyone got into a van
and drove for
14 hours you know 14 hours i i had to
fly but i'm getting in the van back with
him i'm not looking forward to it
there was one flight left to champaign
apparently a bustling airport but a kid
came up and he talked to me after smu
and he said uh you know your show saved
my life i know that sounds like well how
could
he said i was i felt so alone um and i
was very depressed
and i'm a conservative on campus and i
was constantly vilified and as i came
out of the class as a conservative i've
lost friends
and i think i i won't get into private
details but this is someone who
obviously has some some mental health
issues
um which is also why by the way i don't
believe in removing fundamental human
rights for people who have mental health
issues because
that's one thing when we talk about not
wanting to stigmatize all gun owners
i think it's also important to not
stigmatize anyone who has ptsd
or someone who has a teenager was
depressed and miserable because they
tried to whack them out on drugs
because they weren't more like kids and
then tell them they can't own a gun to
protect themselves because
they have some issues um he said i was
depressed
apparently uh i shouldn't say kid
apparently ptsd apparently this is
someone who i believe served it wasn't
entirely clear
you never know with the left sometimes
they'll say ptsd because we came on
campus but i do believe
this one actually had it he said you
know really i was depressed i was in a
bad place it was suicidal
and watching this show made me feel less
alone and here's the thing
the only point to this and this is we
want to arm you guys arm gosh we're
gonna get in trouble
with the ability to provide information
uh to everyone on campus
we want you to all be able to provide
your own arguments this is the opposite
of exclusivity
this is the opposite of having some
secret formula we want to give it out to
as many people as possible
we want all of you to be able to have
these conversations and change minds we
want you to be able to do so in a way
that's productive
you don't listen obviously our show is
pretty offensive but we don't want to
give
you don't want to give the left an
excuse uh just by being a dick and not
being able to substantiate it
that's why we're out here is to make
sure that you guys don't feel alone to
make sure that you guys don't feel
afraid
and if you see people like us if you see
us get banned from twitter if you see us
get banned from you if you see us not
able to come up
be able to visit campus i know we see
kids what shot do you have we get these
emails all the time this kid
kid this guy said he was really
depressed and it made him feel
less alone and this is one thing that i
think everybody needs to understand
i think changed my mind this this whole
conversation has helped
you see with black lives matter you see
with the idea of male privilege
you see with the idea of modern feminism
you see it with antifa
and by the way here's the thing i
understand that some of these people
have had
some pretty bad breaks in these groups i
understand that some of them have
legitimate grievances
but what i also understand is they do
not have a corner on feeling alone
or on being afraid none of them do no
one has a corner on being afraid no one
has a corner and having a tough life
listen
black lives matter coming out and
talking about systemic discrimination i
get that this guy might have had a bad
encounter but are you going to tell me
that just because of the melanin in his
skin his experience was worse than a guy
who came in
out of the military from an abusive
alcoholic father who was suicidal with
ptsd felt so alone he was close to
blowing his brains out
and then what helped him was watching a
show with not gay jared and i dressed up
like swedish twins
that should tell you how afraid people
are right now out there
and the reason we do this the reason we
came here and showed up and like i said
i know it's not ideal we really wanted
to put on something else for you guys
is just because i want you all to
understand that you don't
have to be afraid there are a lot of
things to be afraid of speaking up is
not one of them
the fact that you're here should bolster
your confidence look
look everyone here there's a movement
right now and i've been around for a
long time there's a movement of foot
that i have not
seen since i've been involved since i've
been alive
this is an opportunity right now and
everyone look at this this would have
not happened five years ago
this would have not happened right after
barack obama was elected and not only
did it happen
it happened without riots it happened
without looting and it happened when we
actually seated people down
and you were more polite to them than
they were to you even though you watch a
show that has people like [ __ ] bain
and my half asian lawyer telling twitter
to go [ __ ] themselves
you can have fun and you can still be
productive and above all else do not be
afraid we love you guys so much let him
hear your warrior
everyone god bless you
god bless you always someday thank you
[Music]